[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 europe le premier de cette année
2010 9 au combien importante pour le
vieux continent avec évidemment les
élections européennes au mois de mai au
programme de cette émission un reportage
consacré à une association basée dans le
val d'oise et qui agit depuis de
nombreuses années pour maintenir le lien
social et favoriser l'insertion des
personnes les plus fragiles ensemble
pour le développement humain propose
notamment du renforcement scolaire et
bénéficie dans ce cadre de fonds
européens
nous avons pu les suivre lors d'un
atelier le reportage est à suivre dès le
début de cette émission
geoffroy didier sera notre invité pour
l'interview politique enregistré au
parlement européen de strasbourg le
député européen les républicains
évoquera notamment les élections à venir
pour son parti les sondages sont
difficiles pour l air en plein mouvement
des gilet jaune pas de quoi s'inquiéter
nous dira geoffroy didier et puis en fin
d'émission vous retrouverez notre
séquence consacrée à une date qui a
marqué l'histoire de l'europe
ce mois ci c'est les débuts de la
politique agricole commune en 1962 et
notre comparaison européenne dédiée ce
mois-ci aussi aux systèmes carcéraux en
europe
[Musique]
elle est implantée depuis 14 ans à
villiers-le-bel dans le val-d'oise
l'association ensemble pour le
développement humain oeuvre depuis ses
nombreuses années dans une dynamique
locale en faveur des publics les plus
fragiles socialement elle bénéficie de
fonds européens pour soutenir son action
et parmi ses nombreuses activités il y à
du soutien scolaire pour les plus jeunes
c'est l'un de ces ateliers que nous
avons suivi toute une après midi
reportage à 50 euros
nash est ce un clip qui crient leur
chagrin pas de repos même le mercredi
après midi pour ses enfants de villiers
le bel
à l'heure où la plupart de leurs
camarades s'amuser jouent eux sont en
plein renforcement scolaire et en a qui
sont très très fort en français mais
alors on mathématiques et ça leur bête
noire
on n'y arrive pas ben justement on va
valoriser ce qu'il sait et lui même il
viendra aider quelqu'un qui aura des
difficultés aux mathématiques
enfin en français par contre c'est qu'il
travaillera c'est mathématique et il
verra que ce n'est ce n'est pas un
monstre est qu'on peut le vaincre
vaincre le monstre des mathématiques ou
du français s'est donc l'ambition de ces
ateliers
pour y parvenir le travail est essentiel
le cadre aussi
asseyez-vous merci c'est des règles qui
qui leur permettent déjà de ceux de se
valoriser eux mêmes ils nous sommes
quelqu'un je ne suis pas n'importe qui
ils sont accueillis un parent c'est
c'est un accueil individuel avec tout le
respect qui se doit des règles mais
aussi de la bienveillance à l'heure du
goûter les enfants sont invités à
prendre la parole pour dévoiler leur
meilleure note
s'il vous plaît et vous ont écouté
écouter les g1 très bien en français
pour aider ces enfants issus de milieux
sociaux fragile l'association peut
s'appuyer sur un réseau d'une
cinquantaine de bénévoles
elle bénéficie également depuis deux ans
des fonds européens et 47 mille euros en
tout devenu essentiel pour son activité
actuellement nous savons plus de 215
inscrits et qui suivent le programme
au sein de notre association et on n'a
plus de sens en attente
si l'action est renouvelée si les fonds
sont renouvelés ça nous permettra de
pouvoir donner la chance aux autres
quoi qu'il arrive le pdh poursuivra son
activité en faveur des écoliers avec
toujours une seule et même ambition
depuis ses débuts les épées des absents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un autre volet des fonds européens peut
être moins connu le soutien à la
recherche scientifique et médicale pour
en parler nous recevons à présent lucia
sinkou et bonsoir ça vous êtes
directrice dando diag une entreprise
basée à paris spécialisée dans le
diagnostic et le traitement de
l'endométriose alors c'est une maladie
on va contextualiser tout de suite qui
touche aujourd'hui une femme sur dix
dans le monde qui peuvent tomber
enceinte
et ce n'est pas la plus connue des
maladies pourtant on va le voir en vente
par les les conséquences de cette
maladie peuvent être très graves
déjà avec vos mots à vous de
spécialistes du sujet ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce qu'est l'endométriose dans
ses grandes lignes
bien sûr donc l'un de mes trios c'est
une maladie multifactorielle
certains l'appellent un syndrome est
donc sans rentrer trop dans le médical
et ce qui se passe c'est que le tissu
qui est censé être à l'intérieur de
l'utérus des femmes
il se retrouve à l'extérieur et il va
s'accrocher et poussé dans la cavité
péritonéale donc vous allez vous à
retrouver sur d'autres organes
résultat on des symptômes très
différents
principalement de la douleur localisée à
des endroits différents et plus tard la
maladie progresse donc c'est une
condition chronique
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de thérapie
définitive de l'infertilité pour 40% je
crois des fondations d'un dossier de
l'infertilité et une vie qui devient de
plus en plus difficile des fatigues
chroniques des absences du travail et
après d'autres sont automatiques plus
grave quitté pente douce cette maladie
en fait va pousser donc beaucoup de
beaucoup de conséquences on le disait
des chiffres importants 10% des femmes
aujourd'hui en âge de procréer qui sont
concernés on estime à du coup à 180
millions de femmes concernés ce sont des
chiffres impressionnants
comment vous expliquez finalement ce
décalage entre de tels chiffres
et puis la méconnaissance on va dire du
grand public mais aussi presque
scientifique du sujet alors on va dire
ça s'explique à la fois par
sans faire de clichés mais ça s'explique
à la fois par le fait que c'est une
maladie qui est lié donc au tissu des
règles donc des douleurs liées aux
règles
ça a été considéré pendant des décennies
entre longtemps normal après vous avez
surtout de santé qui sont à spécifiques
dont vous avez mal et la fertilité vous
la découvrirez que quand vous essayez
d'avoir des enfants
résultat on ne prend pas forcément c'est
une maladie qui a plusieurs formes et
des proportions différentes
c'est dans les femmes donc il est très
difficile de poser un diagnostic pour un
clinicien
non seulement il faut être effectivement
sensibiliser à la maladie encore ont un
généraliste va peut-être pas y penser
tout de suite et en plus chaque femme va
avoir une garde est sans doute très
différents et aujourd'hui vous vous
disiez le diagnostic c'est à peu près
neuf ans pour le poser pour aujourd'hui
c'est la somme de deux problèmes un que
la seule manière pour faire un
diagnostic définitif c'est un geste
chirurgical
vous voyez bien que jeune fille de 15
ans avant de décider de l'envoyer au
bloc on y réfléchit et deux de ces
symptômes peuvent aussi être liés à
d'autres pathologies
alors vous et l'entreprise en do dièse
vous travaillé sur le sujet depuis 2011
on va on va résumer sur trois grands
axes la détection précoce de la maladie
pour avancer sur le sujet la recherche
de nouveaux traitements est aussi
l'orientation des décisions pour on va
dire caractérisé la maladie pour pour
chaque patiente et c'est sur ce sujet là
précisément que vous bénéficiez de fonds
européens pour le projet qu'on appelle
en deux grammes tout à fait ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler plus précisément
dans de vrais plaisirs dont 1,2 g c'est
c'est une programme phare de matières
médecine personnalisée pour la renommer
trio a donc j'ai effectivement on a déjà
mentionné c'est une maladie très
hétérogène
chaque femme a dit la vie différemment
répondent différemment au peu de
traitements à prouver qu'ils existent et
la deuxième la deuxième mon dire
problématique c'est que aujourd'hui il
manque manque d'outils même pour les
cliniciens experts les chirurgiens les
anatomopathologistes pour savoir comment
mieux prendre en charge cette maladie
éviter que la patiente reviennent en
chirurgie et deux ans plus tard ou
qu'elle fasse des chirurgies au cours de
sa vie donc c'est l'âme de meute rieuse
des cliniciens disent souvent il
faudrait pas parler d'endométriose mais
de une endométriose comme clos dit j'ai
un cancer c'est le mien bat g une
endométriose à ce que chaque passion de
la vie les choses différemment et puis à
des conséquences différentes sur son
corps aujourd'hui c'est là le la valeur
on va dire qu'on veut apporter avec un
programme de médecine personnalisée à la
fois améliorer
comment les prélèvements de tissus qui
permettent de guider le clinicien dans
ses choix sont faits et surtout des
informations donc des tests
diagnostiques associés qui permet de
savoir si la patiente une forme
agressive de guider le traitement de
l'infertilité le plus adapté et
éventuellement aussi essayer de mieux
comprendre pourquoi cette douleur est si
différente d'une patiente à l'autre une
dernière question pour conclure cet
entretien pourquoi avoir demandé à
bénéficier d'aidés des fonds européens
est ce que ça apporte de la légitimité
au projet scoci ça lui donne on va dire
une une ampleur européennes
continentales exactement ce qu'on venait
de dire nous sommes c'est un privilège
c'est un label de qualité du projet
scientifique derrière donc ça beaucoup
ça nous donne beaucoup de crédibilité
auprès des cliniciens qui travaillent
avec nous et encore une fois c'est une
c'est une maladie très complexe donc ce
n'est qu'hier un effort
multidisciplinaire qui est donc primé
par ce genre de financement qui permet
d'y apporter des réponses adaptées
merci lucia sinkou et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions d'être venu sur notre
plateau de nous avoir aussi éclairer sur
cette maladie l'endométriose qui ont le
rappel concerne 180 millions de femmes
aujourd'hui dans le monde
plus d'informations d'ailleurs sont
disponibles sur la maladie et vos
recherches à vous sur www.nvidia.fr
merci merci encore direction à présent
le parlement européen de strasbourg pour
l'interview politique de ce set 8 europe
l'invité ce mois-ci et geoffroy et
didier eurodéputés les républicains les
actualités et sujets sont forcément
nombreux à quelques semaines des
élections européennes regarder
[Musique]
et nous sommes donc désormais au
parlement européen de strasbourg avec
geoffroy didier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes secrétaire général délégué les
républicains vice président de la région
ile de france et depuis décembre 2010
est vous êtes aussi désormais eurodéputé
vous venez donc de fêter vos un an ici
au parlement européen vous avez remplacé
constance le grip qui est devenu un
député national on dit souvent que c'est
difficile ici de se repérer c'est une
méga structure un peu un peu impersonnel
est ce que vous partagez cet avis est ce
qu'au bout d'un an ça y est vous êtes un
peu comme chez vous ici au parlement
européen comme chez moi n'ont pas tout
de suite et il est vrai que c'est une
machine qui est complexe qui est
difficile à appréhender
et ce qui me plaît ici c'est que ce sont
ceux qui travaillent ce sont les plus
méritants ce sont ceux qui
s'investissent véritablement dans les
dossiers techniques quelle que soit
d'ailleurs la place sous le statut
qu'ils puissent occuper dans leur pays
d'origine de leur pays d'élection qui
sont les mieux à même de porter les
couleurs de l'europe et les couleurs de
leur pays au sein de l'union européenne
donc depuis un an je suis me suis
surtout concentré sur ma nouvelle
mission gens mesurent la difficulté je
relève aussi évidemment ce défi était
très complexe et que dont nous allons
sans doute parler s'agissant de la
campagne des élections européennes
en tout cas je me plais oui justement
les élections européennes cédant quatre
mois le 26 mai prochain précisément en
france on ne connaît pas encore les
candidats de votre part si on connaît
les candidats de certains partis franck
soit françois xavier
bellamy et est pressenti pour être tête
de liste on connaît bien sûr tv sont dit
puisqu'il est élu à versailles votre nom
ainsi à vous aussi été évoqués
connaît-il concrètement est-ce que vous
avez des précisions nous apporter ce que
vous déjà vous serez candidat romney
prochain pour l'instant je me concentre
sur ma mission et j'essaie de bien faire
mon travail au parlement parce que
les français nous regardent surtout dans
des périodes délicates sur le plan
politique et je crois qu'ils sont
surtout attentifs à la manière dont on
exerce son mandat
plutôt que de se poser la question de
savoir quel sera son avenir personnel
non mais les dossiers vont continuer les
dossiers vont continuer savoir aussi
d'un problème psychologique pour vous de
savoir si vous savez où il va y avoir un
sélectionneur de l'équipe c'est laurent
wauquiez qui tire sa légitimité des
urnes puisqu'il est président des
républicains et qui va choisir non pas
seulement une tête de liste mais une
équipe par son devoir se réaliser
champion d'europe ou pas chacun sera à
sa place et nous verrons bien qui sera
le mieux à même pour porter les couleurs
mais j'insiste vraiment sur le travail
d'équipé que nous allons devoir tous
menés avec des sensibilités différentes
de la droite qui vont devoir s'exprimer
avec des territoires différents et avec
chacun son expérience ou son
inexpérience qui n'est évidemment pas
sans qu un inconvénient les élections
européennes seront un test le premier
pour laurent wauquiez président de l air
les sondages pour l'instant alors vous
allez me dire que ce ne sont que des
sondages sont pas très bons 10% vous
fait la course avec debout la france
est-ce que cela vous inquiète-t-il
vraiment comme on vous l'expliquait déjà
possible pour pourrait l'air inquiet non
d'abord on n'avance pas en politique
avec des inquiétudes et des angoisses
on avance avec des convictions et les
solutions et puis c'est pas un test avec
des lauriers c'est 10 % c'est c'est une
première c'est une photographie à
l'instant t d'un institut de sondage
c'est une humeur de quelques français
interrogés ça ne veut rien dire et vous
observerez d'ailleurs toujours qu'il ya
un décalage permanent entre les sondages
d'un côté et la réalité des votes des
français de l'autre mais lorsqu'on parle
de test on parle avant tout d'un test
pour emmanuel macron parce que c'est
élections européennes ça va être une
sorte de mid term
pour le président de la république et on
voit bien à quel point il ya décalage
entre
ce qu'il avait promis à beaucoup de
français qui ont cru qu'ils seraient
peut-être un président réformateur avec
des réformes structurelles qu'ils
appelaient de leurs voeux
et puis la réalité des faits ou on a un
président aujourd'hui qui navigue à vue
qui a perdu totalement le gouvernail et
qui ne sait plus où il habite
ce sera évidemment à un moment compliqué
les élections européennes pourquoi parce
que c'est toujours plus facile de
retenir le message de marine le pen ou
de jean luc mélenchon marine le pen qui
veut être le fossoyeur justement on peut
on peut peut-être découvrir votre
message à vous pour les élections
européennes est ce qu'il ya des
thématiques que vous par exemple ont
bien sûr été portée principalement des
sujets de de fonds que vous allez mettre
en avant d'abord je veux rappeler une
évidence c'est que nous sommes
profondément européen nous sommes
profondément européen s'est posé la
question parfois notamment avec là vous
avez l'art est nier certaines
déclarations laissé entendre que vous
avez la réponse
et maintenant les choses se clarifient
dans le débat vous avez effectivement le
front national qui sont les fossoyeurs
de l'europe
larry viennent chercher leur paye chaque
mois à bruxelles ou à strasbourg mais
pour mieux détruire l'europe ce sont des
destructeurs et nous nous sommes
profondément européen parce que nous
sommes les héritiers d'un projet d'une
culture d'une civilisation et parce que
c'est notre intérêt d'être européens
convaincus que l'union fait la force
en revanche c'est bien parce que nous
sommes européens et que nous sommes de
cette patriote que nous devons changer
l'europe ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
par exemple une robe qui se protègent
davantage
il faut arrêter d'imaginer que l'on peut
supprimer les frontières à l'intérieur
sans avoir des frontières extérieures
étanche
ça ne marchera pas une fois au maître
des frontières internes ou but laurent
society et renforcer les frontières
extérieures
par exemple en multipliant le budget de
l'agencé frontex c'est à dire le corps
depuis longtemps mais ça mais ça n'est
pas véritablement fait c'est décidé
parfois à bruxelles mais ça n'est pas
mise en oeuvre sur le terrain et puis il
ya une question de budget j'estime
aujourd'hui que le devons aller à
l'essentiel et l'essentiel pour garder
la crédibilité en europe
c'est évidemment avoir des frontières
extérieures étanche et puis autre chose
du bon sens
des évidences on peut pas accepter
l'idée par exemple que au sein de
l'union européenne 100 % de nos marchés
publics européens soit ouvert à des
entreprises non européennes et que aux
états unis ce soit seulement 30 % en
chine vous savez combien ces 0%
donc nous ce que nous demandons c'est
un principe de réciprocité dans les
échanges commerciaux c'est à dire que
nous ne je ne dis pas qu'il ya un modèle
qui est mieux que l'autre je dis juste
que il faut que ça est bien là dans
cinq villes
ping face à mes biens bien entendu et
pour ça il faut une europe forte une
europe solide et une réplique de la
volonté politique et il sera peut-être
question de politique agricole commune
pour ces élections c'est en tout cas son
histoire que nous avons décidé de vous
raconter dans notre rubrique ce jour là
et c'est en janvier 1962 que les
premiers accords européens sont signés
sur la pac les précisions de philippe le
guen coordinateur adjoint pour le
parlement européen de la maison jean
monnet basée à bazoches sur guyonne dans
les yvelines enfin disons que la pac
c'est une grande politique européenne
qui était prévu dès le départ dans le
traité de rome de 1957 puisque le
principe fondamental de ce traité et qui
région encore aujourd'hui c'est la libre
circulation et notamment des
marchandises est donc évidemment
concernant les marchandises agricoles
comme il y avait des grandes disparités
de prix et des deux niveaux de
production entre les pays membres
il fallait évidemment pour que cette
libre circulation fonctionne qui est une
grande politique agricole commune donc
on peut dire que cette grande politique
agricole commune a été une des premières
de l'europe
et qu'elle a quand même rempli son son
son rôle qui était d'une part
d'augmenter la production de garantir un
revenu décent aux agriculteurs et de
maintenir des prix abordables
alors évidemment au fil du temps il ya
eu des réformes puisque bon on est passé
de l'époque on était six pays à 27 est
donc effectivement avec des nouveaux des
nouvelles conditions des nouveaux
besoins des pays qui sont quittés en
europe centrale et orientale qui était
très en retard au niveau de la
production aussi au niveau des la
mécanisation de l'agriculture
on a eu des périodes où il a fallu
réguler parce que on se souvient dans
les années 80 de la période des
montagnes de beurre 1 comme à l'aller
les allemands les avait appelés les
bouteurs bergues
donc il y avait une surproduction donc
ce qui a généré des quotas un en
particulier au niveau laitiers des
produits laitiers bon quota qu'il a
fallu ensuite revoir de manière
différente
évidemment on était aussi dans une pop
politique au départ assez
protectionnistes de des pays européens
qui voulaient se nourrir avec la
production de
de leur pays de leurs agriculteurs
évidemment il a fallu adapter tout cela
aux règles du marché mondial de l'om c
et c est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment on peut plus être en autarcie
alimentaires produits agricoles et qu'il
faut s'adapter aux cours mondiaux
bon ça a été les principes ou les
principaux défis pour cette politique
avec all commune et nous sommes encore
maintenant avec un nouveau défi qui est
celui de l'environnement celui du
développement rural qui petit à petit
est venu changer à des orientations qui
était strictement agricole geoffroy
didier des thématiques vont peut-être
émerger de ce débat national qui vient
de débuter et qui vont du coup prendre
de l'ampleur au moment des débats des
élections européennes vous avez dit vous
les républicains que vous seriez prêt à
participer vous êtes prêts à participer
activement à ce débat d'être force de
proposition je vous cite qu'est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils aient le plus
important aujourd'hui ce qu'il ya une
thématique dans celles qui sont
proposées aux français qu'il faut mettre
en avant particulièrement où là il faut
être force de proposition pour les
républicains
bien entendu par respect pour l'esprit
des gilet jaune il faut revenir à la
base du message de tous ceux qui auront
fils et un gilet jaune ou de tout ce
qu'ils n'ont pas enfilé parce qu'ils ne
le pouvaient pas mais qui ont exprimé un
mouvement de sympathie à leur égard
c'est ce ras-le-bol fiscale nous
détenons le record absolu en termes de
prélèvements obligatoires des pays de l'
ocde
ça ne peut pas durer donc si les gie les
jeunes ont manifesté ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas payer l'impôt
c'est qu'ils ne le peuvent pas donc il
faut baisser les impôts se basait sous
les 1 euro n par exemple exactement tous
les impôts mais pour ça vous savez il
n'y a pas de mystère il faut baisser la
dépense publique
ça veut dire qu'il faut baisser les
doublons ça veut dire que les
républicains ont fait un grand nombre de
propositions mais par exemple la
location sociale unique qui est plafonné
à 75% du smic pour que le travail
rémunère toujours mieux que la
solidarité ou que dans certaines
situations malheureusement l'assistanat
le fait qu'on veuille aligner des
régimes le sait les régimes de retraite
du secteur public sur le secteur privé
le fait par exemple qu'on supprime tous
les régimes spéciaux de retraite qu'on
supprime les niches fiscales ou
supprime aussi vous savez il ya
vingt-six autorité administrative
indépendante de notre pays il ya quatre
cent quarante et un observatoire et au
commissariat le rebond de revêtement de
serre de en france on observe beaucoup
en france
mais ce que les français observent
pendant ce temps ce sont leurs feuilles
d'impôts et ils en ont ras-le-bol et
cette exaspération est légitime et vous
avouerez qu'emmanuel macron n'a fait
qu'augmenter les impôts au parlement
européen on vous parle de cette crise
des gilet jaune certains de vos
collègues sur remparts sont identiques
et qui a été le regard j'ai peut-il bien
sûr ce mouvement est ce qui me préoccupe
c'est que et ça je reconnaissais à
emmanuel macron le fait d'avoir redoré
l'image de la france en europe et dans
le monde au moment de son élection parce
que il y avait un espoir qui renaissait
du fait de sa jeunesse mais aussi du
fait de ce nouveau souffle qui
produisait partout dans le monde
et patatras badaboum en 18 mois il a
totalement supprimée cet élan est
aujourd'hui les français nous regarde
les les européens où évidemment partout
dans le monde on ne regarde avec pitié
ou avec inquiétude et les deux
sentiments ne sont pas bons ne sont pas
bons pour notre pays ils sont pas bons
pour son attractivité
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il va falloir à
mon avis être très fort sur le message
que nous allons adresser vos demandes la
campagne des européennes et moi ce sera
un message positif je veut réformer
l'europe parce que nous en avons besoin
un autre pays on va se va se quitter là
dessus se trouve pour bien d'autres
raisons dans une situation très
compliquée aujourd'hui c'est le royaume
uni le flou continue de persister sur ce
break site
impossible de dire ce qui va se passer
d'ici le 29 mars prochain
ou peut-être plus tard qu'elle quels
commentaires vous en tirez vos quelques
jugements vous en tirez cola des
pronostics qui sont effectivement
irréalisable ce qu'on a la preuve
vivante que le programme du front
national est un suicide collectif c'est
à dire que vouloir supprimer le l'euro
parce que si vous foncez ça qu'ils ont
décidé de l'abandonner aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est ce que dit le rythme oui
mais d'accord mais si vous croyez ce que
dit marine le pen effectivement vous
n'êtes pas sorti d'affaires parce que
tout programme économique du front
national est basé sur la sortie de
l'euro pour en fait on nous ment et on
continue à nous lancer les britanniques
n'avaient pas l'heureux ils sont sortis
de ligne auront bien sûr mais ce serait
encore pire justement pour un pays de
sortir de l'union européenne alors même
qu'il à l'euro donc vous imaginez
aujourd'hui ce que subissent les
britanniques avec le bric site
vous imaginez aussi ce que nous devrions
subir notamment évidemment sur les
retraites de tous ceux du pouvoir
d'achat en termes de frais que si ça
avait lieu donc moi je le dis à ceux qui
nous regardent et à ceux qui nous
écoutent le programme du front national
est un suicide collectif
et quand je dis front national c'est
aussi bien marine le pen que nicolas
dupont aignan parce qu'il ya un nom il
voulait de sa production premier
ministre on termine cette émission avec
notre dernier à rubrique consacrée à une
comparaison européenne on s'intéresse au
moins six au système carcéral en europe
alors que la prison de la santé a
rouvert en janvier à paris le point avec
olivier jeanne l'ex responsable du
centre europe direct à saint germain en
laye alors pour les pays qui emprisonne
le moins on a tout d'abord donc les pays
bas où il ya 53 détenus pour 100000
habitants qui on à la finlande avec 54,8
détenus pour 100000 habitants et la
suède avec 58,6 détenus pour cent mille
habitants
les pays-bas ont une politique de
gestion de la délinquance et de la
criminalité qui est radicalement
différente de la nôtre on va dire qu'ils
passent davantage de temps sur la
sensibilisation et la prévention en
amont avec notamment pas mal de cours de
sensibilisation à la civilité à la
citoyenneté qui sont donnés aux enfants
et aussi pour les
et détenus ils n'hésitent ils n'hésitent
pas non plus à expulser notamment les
détenus étrangers qui ont commis des
infractions aux pays bas et qui sont
emprisonnés aux pays-bas les pays qui
ont le plus gros taux d'incarcération ce
sont les pays baltes donc avec la
lituanie qui en tête avec 277 7 détenus
pour 100000 habitants suivie par la
lettonie 223,4 détenus pour 100000
habitants et enfin l'estonie avec 200
210 3 détenus pour 100000 habitants et
la france se situe plutôt dans la
tranche basse avec 98 des tenues pour
cent mille habitants
la surpopulation carcérale est un
phénomène qui est connu par certains
pays de l'union européenne alors
principalement par neuf pays donc ça
reste une situation qui en minorité
principalement le pays qui est le plus
qui connaît le plus la population
population carcérale c'est la hongrie ou
en fait il y à 129 détenues pour 100
places
la hongrie est suivi en fait par la
belgique avec 127 détenues pour 100
places
et la france avec 113 des 213 détenues
pour 100 places
quand on regarde les la composition de
la population carcérale
c'est une très grande majorité
dom on estime qu'il ya à peu près 5% au
niveau de l'union européenne on estime
qu'il ya cinq ans en deux femmes qui
sont en prison merci je crois didier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés et
l'air d'ile-de-france eurodéputés parce
que je suis pas député la zone euro fut
député au parlement européen
c'est ce que j'ai envie de rebondir mais
tel que c'est une erreur je ne sais pas
mais vous êtes député de l'union
européenne exactement lr on est des
français pour représenter la france au
sein de l'union européenne aussi
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france assez bon et secrétaire
général délégué républicain c'est la fin
de ce seigneur europe
merci aussi aux équipes du parlement
pour la lisa sion de cet entretien on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
vous retrouvez en replay cette émission
sur tv 70 points comme et nos réseaux
sociaux tb 78 merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]